la policía Busca pistas en el interior
de esta gran tienda Walmart en chisepic
Virginia después de que un hombre armado
matar a varias personas
a las 10:12 pm respondimos a un informe
de un tiroteo en Walmart aquí en Sam's
Drive localizamos múltiples víctimas
mortales y múltiples heridos creemos que
se trata de un solo tirador y ese único
tirador Ha fallecido en este momento
los relatos de los Testigos en los
medios de comunicación locales sugieren
que después de su matanza el tirador se
apuntó a él mismo dentro de una sala de
descanso del personal se desconocen sus
motivos pero se cree que al sospechoso
era un empleado de la tienda la policía
pasó horas peinando el complejo tratando
de encontrar pruebas pero también
posibles supervivientes escondidos del
ataque en un tuit Walmart dijo estar
conmocionado por el trágico suceso
añadiendo que la empresa estaba
trabajando estrechamente con las fuerzas
del orden y se centraba en apoyar a sus
Asociados espantosos sucesos se produce
justo antes de Acción de Gracias uno de
los periodos de mayor actividad para el
gigante minorista los legisladores de
virginia han expresado su conmoción y
rabia por el más reciente hecho de
violencia con armas de fuego que ha
tenido lugar en su estado mientras que
un usuario de Twitter resumió en un
diagrama el círculo vicioso de inacción
que lleva a que hechos como este se
repitan constantemente los asesinatos se
producen solo unos días después de otro
mortífero tiroteo en un club nocturno
gay de Colorado el sábado el sospechoso
de este ataque un hombre de 22 años Fue
detenido y se enfrenta a múltiples
cargos de asesinato y delitos de hoy